[Musik]
hey was geht ab und herzlich willkommen
bei einem neuen video
ich hoffe natürlich euch ist gut mir
auch wir haben heute nämlich etwas
spannendes vor und zwar wollen wir unser
wohnzimmer jetzt sich umdekorieren aber
ein bisschen umfunktionieren sagen das
war so das ding ist ich hab halt ein
fernseher in meinem zimmer mein
mitbewohner hat auf dem feld sein seinem
zimmer wir haben allerdings keinen fährt
hier im wohnzimmer hat also man kann das
wir sehen von ihr wir haben da dieses
bild hängen
und da ist eigentlich so ein
fernsehtisch allerdings ohne fernseher
überlegt ob wir uns einen fernseher
holen allerdings ist jetzt was cooles
passiert und zwar ist die firma
viewsonic auf mich zugekommen habt ihr
was zugeschickt und zwar den neuen sonic
4 k ultra hd ist ein beamer was echt
cool sein soll
das teilt ist helligkeits resistent das
heißt egal wie hält es hat trotzdem ein
klares bild wie auf einem fernseher und
der plan für das heutige video ist dass
wir das bild umhängen wir bauen hier ein
bisschen um und wir hätten dann gerne in
unserem wohnzimmer
diese komplette weiße wand praktisch
bild also kein xxl fernsehen sondern
einfach einen heftigen beamer hinstellen
und darauf dann ein bisschen playstation
spielen ich bin mal gespannt wie das aus
und ihr habt richtig bock drauf ich
persönlich habe euren playstation auch
ein beamer gespielt deswegen werden sich
dafür sollten wir das als erstes
allerdings aufpassen so sieht das also
aus circa ultra hd
hatte neue wert von über 1000 euro link
zum produkt ist der video beschreibung
so also beschreibung strom noch mehr
strom verbindungskabel hier die
fernbedienung die irgendwie erst gerade
hell leuchtet die immer und er wird zum
wichtigsten part der beamer also auf
jeden fall selbst geäußert muss ja auch
so sein und es ist wirklich dann fällt
es teilt also ich hab mir das sogar ein
bisschen kleiner vorgestellt haben wir
einmal die linse jeden regel zum
scharfstellen an und ausschalter ein
paar einstellungsmöglichkeiten menü und
so weiter und hier hinten die ganzen
anschlüsse hdmi für playstation und so
weiter ist natürlich ganz wichtig und
auch den strom zugang
also ich würde sagen so sieht's aus und
wir brauchen jetzt erstmal eine
vernünftige koalition
und dann hoffe ich haben wir gleich ein
geist bild dort auf der wand wo man
vernünftig zeigen kann
ich bin auf jeden fall schon begeistert
sondern ich erst mal das bild ja weil
wir brauchen die ganze weiße sand das
neue jahr reist möglich was meinst du
von mir bis hier soll es ja schon alles
voll
[Musik]
wer gut so so jetzt haben wir eine geile
weiße wand der beamer müsste jetzt werde
überlegt ob wir den unter die decke
schrauben oder ob wir denn erstmal hier
hinstellen und schauen wenn wir uns für
das zweite entschieden weist dann
natürlich auch leichter ist playstation
und so weit haben zu verbinden
deswegen habe ich jetzt einen schrank
besorgt er will jetzt hier hingestellt
und darauf platzieren wir aber erstmal
den beamer so leute halte ich glaube das
ist eine ganz gute position ist erst mal
vielleicht müsst ihr sogar noch ein
bisschen höher aber du kannst du ja
hinterher bw kabel sollte der riemer ist
jetzt an den strom angeschlossen
ich drücke jetzt mal hier soweit also
natürlich kann man das doch noch größer
machen das bild je nachdem ob er schaue
ich mir meine playstation holt die
verbinden wir mal schnell alles muss
allen die qualität ist wirklich gut
macht man hier nicht aus wir uns
natürlich auch ein bisschen nicht von
draußen aber den soll der helligkeit
nicht wirklich etwas anhaben
ich würde sagen wir stellen jetzt mal
die beiden studieren und spielen eine
party fifa gehen
natürlich kann man darüber auch fernseh
gucken oder youtube videos schauen das
sage ich euch aber schnell aber man muss
ehrlich sagen ich hoffe ihr könnt es auf
der kamera ist auch sehen die qualität
des gestochen scharf
leute ich bin jetzt einzigen 1 hiermit
kann ich ganz einfach erstellen wobei
man halt auch externe boxen anschließen
kann aber die sind auch produkte also
leute ich muss sagen ich bin wirklich
von der qualität überzeugt dass es echt
krass ist wie auf einem wirklich hd
starten fernseher und das bild ist
riesig fans wahrscheinlich
funktionsvielfalt oder also das bild ist
schon krass was jüngeren noch schneller
altern
[Applaus]
das war stark und in den laufen heute
spieles unentschieden ausgegangen eins
zu eins eigentlich ganz klar und
verdient hier dabei durch das
machtwechsel menge spaß auf so einer
großen display fläche zu zocken wir
wollen jetzt noch mal kurz ein
youtube-video darüber schauen
[Musik]
[Applaus]
danke auf jeden fall ein user weg für
dieses coole gerät hilfe von smart ist
in der herstellung verlinkt ist auf
jeden fall mal anders würde ich sagen
ich hoffe dass wieder durchgefallen wir
schauen jetzt mal so die nächste zeit
wie wir das positionieren werde
vielleicht auch an der walter oder an
der aktion haben wollen sondern auch ein
neues sofa holen und ansonsten bin ich
aber sehr zufrieden waren solche ganz
kurz zu machen ich glaube wir haben
jetzt eine perfekte stelle gefunden die
wand welt komplett angestrahlt und die
ist wirklich so drei meter 3 ich weiß
nicht ob die relation so rüberkommt aber
ich kann es euch mal kurz zeigen also
das ist schon möglich keit und wir
freuen uns recht dass wir zu diesem bild
hier bei uns im wohnzimmer haben
ansonsten nochmals das war's mit dem
video check können wir den biber ab wenn
ihr euch auch besonders interessiert
also ich bin wirklich begeistert also
ohne spaß ist das wahrscheinlich morgen
wieder da gibt es ein neues video und
haut rein